One of you all sent a fairly
interesting problem, so I
thought I would work it out.
The problem is I have a
group of 30 people, so
30 people in a room.
They're randomly
selected 30 people.
And the question is what is the
probability that at least 2
people have the same birthday?
This is kind of a fun question
because that's the size
of a lot of classrooms.
What's the probability that at
least someone in the classroom
shares a birthday with someone
else in the classroom?
That's a good way
to phrase as well.
This is the same thing as
saying, what is the probability
that someone shares with
at least someone else.
They could share it with 2
other people or 4 other
people in the birthday.
And at first this problem seems
really hard because there's
a lot of circumstances
that makes this true.
I could have exactly 2 people
have the same birthday.
I could have exactly 3 people
I could have exactly 29 people
have the same birthday and all
of these make this true, so do
I add the probability of each
of those circumstances?
And then add them up and then
that becomes really hard.
And then I would have to
say, OK, whose birthdays
and I comparing?
And I would have to
do combinations.
It becomes a really difficult
problem unless you make kind
of one very simplifying
take on the problem.
This is the opposite of--
well let me draw the
probability space.
Let's say that this is
all of the outcomes.
Let me draw it with
a thicker line.
So let's say that's all
of the outcomes of my
probability space.
So that's 100% of the outcomes.
We want to know-- let me draw
it in a color that won't
be offensive to you.
That doesn't look that
great, but anyway.
Let's say that this is the
probability, this area right
here-- and I don't know
how big it really is,
we'll figure it out.
Let's say that this is the
probability that someone
shares a birthday with
at least someone else.
What's this area over here?
What's this green area?
Well, that means if these are
all the cases where someone
shares a birthday with someone
else, these are all the area
where no one shares a
birthday with anyone.
Or you could say, all 30 people
have different birthdays.
This is what we're
trying to figure out.
I'll just call it the
probability that
someone shares.
I'll call it the probability
of sharing, probability of s.
If this whole area is area 1 or
area 100%, this green area
right here, this is going
to be 1 minus p of s.
This is going to be
1 minus p of s.
Or if we said that this is the
probability-- or another way we
could say it, actually this is
the best way to think about it.
If this is different, so
this is the probability
of different birthdays.
This is the probability
that all 30 people have
30 different birthdays.
No one shares with anyone.
The probability that someone
shares with someone else plus
the probability that no one
shares with anyone-- they all
have distinct birthdays--
that's got to be equal to 1.
Because we're either going to
be in this situation or we're
going to be in that situation.
Or you can say they're
equal to 100%.
Either way, 100% and 1
are the same number.
It's equal to 100%.
So if we figure out the
probability that everyone has
the same birthday we could
subtract it from 100.
So let's see.
We could we just rewrite this.
The probability that someone
shares a birthday with someone
else, that's equal to 100%
minus the probability that
everyone has distinct,
separate birthdays.
And the reason why I'm doing
that is because as I started
off in the video, this is
kind of hard to figure out.
You know, I can figure out the
probability that 2 people have
the same birthday, 5 people,
and it becomes very confusing.
But here, if I wanted to just
figure out the probability that
everyone has a distinct
birthday, it's actually a much
easier probability
to solve for.
So what's the probability
that everyone has a
distinct birthday?
So let's think about it.
Person one.
Just for simplicity, let's
imagine the case that we only
have 2 people in the room.
What's the probably that they
have different birthdays?
Let's see, person one, their
birthday could be 365 days
out of 365 days of the year.
You know, whenever
their birthday is.
And then person two, if we
wanted to ensure that they
don't have the same birthday,
how many days could
person two be born on?
Well, it could be born
on any day that person
one was not born on.
So there are 364
possibilities out 365.
So if you had 2 people, the
probability that no one
is born on the same
birthday-- this is just 1.
It's just going to be
equal to 364/365.
Now what happens if
we had 3 people?
So first of all the
first person could
be born on any day.
Then the second person could
be born on 364 possible
days out of 365.
And then the third person,
what's the probability that
the third person isn't
born on either of these
people birthdays?
So 2 days are taken up, so
the probability is 363/365.
You multiply them out.
You get 365 times 36-- actually
I should rewrite this one.
Instead of saying this is 1,
let me write this as-- the
numerator is 365 times
364 over 365 squared.
Because I want you
to see the pattern.
Here the probability is 365
times 364 times 363 over
365 to the third power.
And so, in general, if you just
kept doing this to 30, if I
just kept this process for 30
people-- the probability that
no one shares the same birthday
would be equal to 365 times 364
times 363-- I'll have
30 terms up here.
All the way down to what?
All the way down to 336.
That'll actually be 30
terms divided by 365
to the 30th power.
And you can just type this into
your calculator right now.
It'll take you a little time to
type in 30 numbers, and you'll
get the probability that no one
shares the same birthday
with anyone else.
But before we do that let
me just show you something
that might make it a
little bit easier.
Is there any way that I can
mathematically express
this with factorials?
Or that I could mathematically
express this with factorials?
Let's think about it.
365 factorial is what?
365 factorial is equal to 365
times 364 times 363 times--
all the way down to 1.
You just keep multiplying.
It's a huge number.
Now, if I just want the 365
times the 364 in this case,
I have to get rid of all of
these numbers back here.
One thing I could do is I
could divide this thing
by all of these numbers.
So 363 times 362-- all
the way down to 1.
So that's the same thing as
dividing by 363 factorial.
365 factorial divided by 363
factorial is essentially this
because all of these
terms cancel out.
So this is equal to 365
factorial over 363 factorial
over 365 squared.
And of course, for this case,
it's almost silly to worry
about the factorials, but it
becomes useful once we have
something larger than
two terms up here.
So by the same logic, this
right here is going to be equal
to 365 factorial over 362
factorial over 365 squared.
And actually, just another
interesting point.
How did we get this 365?
Sorry, how did we get
this 363 factorial?
Well, 365 minus 2
is 363, right?
And that makes sense because we
only wanted two terms up here.
We only wanted two
terms right here.
So we wanted to divide by a
factorial that's two less.
And so we'd only get the
highest two terms left.
This is also equal to-- you
could write this as 365
factorial divided by 365 minus
2 factorial 365 minus 2 is 363
factorial and then you just end
up with those two terms
and that's that there.
And then likewise, this right
here, this numerator you could
rewrite as 365 factorial
divided by 365 minus 3-- and
we had 3 people-- factorial.
And that should hopefully
make sense, right?
This is the same thing as 365
factorial-- well 365 divided
by 3 is 362 factorial.
And so that's equal to
365 times 364 times
363 all the way down.
Divided by 362 times
all the way down.
And that'll cancel out with
everything else and you'd
be just left with that.
And that's that right there.
So by that same logic, this top
part here can be written as
365 factorial over what?
365 minus 30 factorial.
And I did all of that just so
I could show you kind of the
pattern and because this is
frankly easier to type into a
calculator if you know where
the factorial button is.
So let's figure out what
this entire probability is.
So turning on the calculator,
we want-- so let's
do the numerator.
365 factorial divided by--
well, what's 365 minus 30?
That's 335.
Divided by 335 factorial and
that's the whole numerator.
And now we want to divide
the numerator by 365
to the 30th power.
Let the calculator think
and we get 0.2936.
Equals 0.2936.
Actually 37 if you rounded,
which is equal to 29.37%.
Now, just so you remember what
we were doing all along, this
was the probability that no one
shares a birthday with anyone.
This was the probability of
everyone having distinct,
different birthdays
from everyone else.
And we said, well, the
probability that someone shares
a birthday with someone else,
or maybe more than one person,
is equal to all of the
possibilities-- kind of the
100%, the probability space,
minus the probability that no
one shares a birthday
with anybody.
So that's equal to
100% minus 29.37%.
Or another way you could write
it as that's 1 minus 0.2937,
which is equal to-- so if I
want to subtract that from 1.
1 minus-- that just
means the answer.
That means 1 minus 0.29.
You get 0.7063.
So the probability that someone
shares a birthday with someone
else is 0.7063--
it keeps going.
Which is approximately
equal to 70.6%.
Which is kind of a neat result
because if you have 30 people
in a room you might say,
oh wow, what are the odds
that someone has the same
birthday as someone else?
It's actually pretty high.
70% of the time, if you have a
group of 30 people, at least 1
person shares a birthday
with at least one other
person in the room.
So that's kind of
a neat problem.
And kind of a neat result
at the same time.
Anyway, see you in
the next video.